apples ten point two inch iPad was
released about six months ago and at
that time I told people not to buy it
and just buy the previous nine point
seven inch model instead because it was
on sale and there wasn't a huge
difference between the two especially
since Apple stuck the same exact a ten
ship into the new model but now in 2020
a lot of things have changed and I
actually have three reasons why the ten
point two inch budget iPad is now a
great choice first off the new model is
on sale for two hundred and seventy nine
dollars so it's a much better deal than
before and I'm 100% sure that this is
the best bang for the buck tablet that
you can buy for everything that you get
with the main benefit being the
excellent software that you're getting
Apple software has proven especially
reliable on their iPads it's very
efficient so you won't notice your iPad
getting slower after a year or two of
use like you do with Android tablets and
you continue to get annual software
updates for years after your purchase
which add great features and keep it
running well so just for the fact that
you're getting Apple software for two
hundred and seventy nine dollars is an
excellent deal and in 2020 the software
has changed dramatically with iPad OSS
new features the new multitasking
features we've received with iPad OS 13
were great adding so much more
functionality to the iPad and it's also
great that the 10.2 inch iPad now has
three gigabytes of RAM so that will
definitely help keep it running smoothly
but less than a month ago Apple added
cursor support to the iPad for the first
time ever which is reason number two for
why it's so great cursor support
basically means that you can connect a
bluetooth mouse or trackpad and
literally use your iPad hands-free this
is great for everything from browsing
the web using drag-and-drop within apps
like files or even things like creating
your own website you also get really
great accuracy for things like
occasional photo editing if you choose
to do so
getting into the third reason the 10.2
inch iPad was the first iPad to get AB
smart connector now when I first heard
about this change it didn't really
matter much to me at all because I still
believed that this budget iPad was meant
to be used as a tablet for basic things
and nothing more I'm talking basic
things like browsing through Instagram
watching some YouTube or Netflix and
playing basic and easy to run games like
clash of clans the reason I say easy
games is because the a-10 ship and this
iPad is much weaker than the rest of the
iPads in Apple's lineup for example it
can't handle more demanding games like
fortnight pub G or Call of Duty mobile
very well at all the $400 iPad Mini gets
the a12 chip which is much better suited
for people interested in those types of
games but for basic games like clash
Royale or whatever else this 10.2 inch
iPad is actually fast enough now those
were the reasons why I thought this iPad
doesn't really need the smart connector
but now in 2020 that connector is
actually one of the most important
features of this iPad the reason for
that is because of this keyboard case
right here the brand new Logitech combo
touch for the budget iPad for 150
dollars what's special about this
keyboard case is that it's the first one
ever
for the basic iPad to actually come with
a built-in trackpad this means that as
soon as you put the case on the smart
connector will power the keyboard which
means absolutely no batteries and the
trackpad will instantly connect to your
iPad now this otherwise basic tablet
turns into a full-blown laptop
replacement allowing you to use it just
like you use a MacBook you get both left
and right click on the trackpad along
with all the same gestures and full
cursor support now of course it won't
have the power of a laptop to do things
like use professional apps but for many
people out there who just need a basic
laptop for things like schoolwork and
browsing the web this will get the job
done I honestly believe that the
Logitech combo keyboard case takes this
iPad to a whole new level and it opens
it up to a much larger market than
before and the crazy part is that
that keyboard case this laptop
replacement iPad setup only costs four
hundred and twenty nine dollars which is
getting into Chromebook territory and to
be honest I would recommend this setup
over any Chromebook out there because
you can do so much more with Apple's
reliable and efficient iPad OS software
and you have access to so many more apps
and games that you simply can't get on a
Chromebook now if you're gonna use it as
a laptop replacement I would definitely
recommend going for the 128 gigabyte
storage model and you can even buy one
with LTE cellular service so you don't
have to rely on being connected to Wi-Fi
all the time and now that the
coronavirus has basically shut every
school down through the end of the
academic school year there are a lot of
students doing their work at home and I
think this iPad with that keyboard case
is the perfect setup for doing
schoolwork from home and to make it even
better when you're finished with your
homework you get to enjoy watching
Netflix YouTube browsing through
Facebook or playing games another
excellent use case is for anyone running
a small business with that keyboard case
you can use it like a laptop for things
like browsing the web online banking
running apps like QuickBooks for
invoicing and accounting using Google
Drive or the files out for storing and
sharing files using Microsoft Word or
Excel social media marketing like
Facebook or Instagram creating your own
website with the Squarespace app and you
can even sign documents using the Apple
pencil without having a print sign and
scan them this iPad set up with that
Logitech combo keyboard case is the
perfect setup for a small business owner
looking for a cheap and reliable laptop
now of course those with a higher budget
can spend some extra cash on the $500
iPad air and get a much better display
and more powerful processor but this
basic iPad can handle a lot of common
tasks and the price is just so good that
it's hard to choose any other tablet or
Chromebook over it now the rest of
Apple's current iPads have some
significant improvements like better
display quality better speakers and more
for mints but this budget tempo 2-inch
iPad is good enough for a lot of people
who would rather save a good amount of
cash so all of those reasons are why the
10.2 inch ipad became a much better
tablet in 2020 if you enjoy this review
tap like and click the circle above to
subscribe and if you need help choosing
an iPad in 2020 make sure to check out
that video over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]